CBS News chief Washington correspondent
Face the Nation anchor John Dickerson is
with us from Washington John good
morning morning Charlie so what what
message after this is the country to
think about the president and also about
the challenge facing all of us well the
message from the president over the last
three days has been that the racists in
Charlottesville
but then on sort of the same plane he
put that there was contributory violence
from the counter protesters and I think
the other thing people are left with is
that a president who has made his
reputation and whose supporters always
talk about his bluntness and the
powerful force he speaks about big
truths and maybe doesn't spend so much
time on the facts in this particular
case didn't seem as worked up about the
big truth here which was that you had
new Nazis and white supremacists
marching but seemed really anxious to
wrestle this fact to the ground about
the fact that there were some people on
the Left who were protesting and this is
a lack of proportion when the ideas
we're talking about here are direct
threats and directly in opposition to
the founding principles of the country
he leads well you've got Democrats and
Republicans who are now coming out
criticizing the president who did not
seem to denounce David Duke support what
what do you make of the implications of
that John well for Republicans in
particular they have to distance
themselves from the president and the
question is whether this is anything
that can be repaired because the
president has now spoken twice on this
issue and has not met the moment and you
have particularly for Republicans they
will always be faced with being asked
about this anybody who makes remarks
that can be received approvingly by
Imperial wizard at the KKK David Duke is
just somebody that Republicans can't
embrace and so how do you work on
infrastructure for example now well
Democrats are not going to be able to
vote for anything that's supported by a
president who has said these kinds of
remarks and who seems ready to keep
fighting about this
and and draw the exclusion of all else
john do we expect people who are now
working for the president at the highest
level to say this has gone too far
I cannot stand for this and I have to
leave this administration well it is a
new challenge for for those people
because it's both the specifics of the
case which is the lack of blunt and
clear a blunt and clear message about
thoroughly objectionable ideas but then
it's also about just chaos and and lack
of control in a White House and that and
whether you want to continue being
towards that also this is a I mean it
since each moment and so it's not going
to get much better
John Dickerson thank you for joining us
this morning